he
me
me
it's cold i'm sold and i'm sold on being
bold I'm hollow maybe tomorrow I won't
be in sorrow how long does it take to
grieve when will the pain leave one will
I feel some relief it's like my best
friend doesn't want this friendship to
end but in stages of grief I guess
there's no rules to bend psychologically
speaking psychologically the brains
leaking and my actions are obeying the
impulses I raised my pulse then I
convulse and i repulse what happened to
Greg we used to say break a leg and he
gets [ __ ] done now he don't even come
out to see the shining Sun used to be so
funny Greg what happened dude you want
so happy Greg subconsciously
unconsciously I get dreamy and I get
drowsy then I get friendly and I get
clingy as I hate being stuck at home cuz
when i'm alone anxiety is over flown in
the silent tones can't shut it out with
an ipod and headphones just call me if
you need anything but when i do the
phone just keeps ringing I might even
shoot a text and then I become perplexed
I thought a response would come next we
get it dude you lost two family members
this year and you get your act together
and focus on your career I lost the
important person to me she left me
happily 2013 has been so mean it's like
depression has become my routine you got
to open up but when I do it's like you
want me to shut up it just sounds like
I'm repeating and said you want me to be
entertaining i'm sorry but i guess i'm
now boring first time in a long time
it's hard to identify these feelings
that I probably deny so I try an outcry
and try to make peace by saying goodbye
but it all feels like a lie it's only
been four months as a deaths two months
it's a girl left and i still find myself
trying to catch my breath I'm whining
about the same [ __ ] Greg come on there's
no benefit now I'm afraid of any kind of
connection waiting for love to make its
resurrection not horny yet i get a
biological reaction with this erection I
don't cut anymore for others it makes
people sad and angers but I'm still
tempted so I can be well rested I know
it sounds twisted but it's the way my
body likes to be treated everyone's
saying you look better but when stress
gets me sick I just brush it off I'm
feeling a little under the weather
everyone thinks I made progress but true
thoroughly every night I digress I guess
I haven't changed I guess I haven't
grown not feeling
unchanged I guess I deserve to always
feel alone
me